des femmes des couples qui vont pouvoir
en train de faire l'amour pas que des
photos enfin il y a vraiment de tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'ici
soit vraiment le plus plat on est déjà à
sa deuxième liposuccion en seulement
trois ans
alors en fait moi j'ai fait deux
opérations donc en 2019 j'ai fini
possession et en même temps on avait
fait une bichette tenue parce que
j'avais de la graisse
qu'on a des excès de graisse dans les
joues souvent les présentateurs télé
tout ça ils le font ah oui c'est vrai ça
creuse un peu les yeux
comme Benjamin Castaldi il l'a fait
35 c'est une donc la bichectomie c'est
un excès de graisse qu'on a donc dans
les pectoraux d'accord et donc
parce que j'avais des l'impression
d'avoir des seins en fait c'était
vraiment très très moche
très lourdes et surtout très onéreuse
25000 euros mais Robin ne paiera pas ce
prix là il a obtenu une ristourne de
80%, en signant un contrat commercial
avec le chirurgien je suis avec Docteur
Matt alors docteur maths comment ça va
ça va très bientôt Robin ça va super moi
j'ai fait un partenariat avec Docteur
math parce que je l'apprécie tout
particulièrement il a traité ma mère par
contre il y a eu des propos vraiment
polémiques zone interdites a tenu
d'ailleurs moi je me suis arnaqué par
zone interdite complètement pourquoi ils
t'ont dit quoi son interdit moi il
m'avait démarché en fait parce que tout
simplement je suis comédien en même
temps de ça je suis chef d'entreprise et
en même temps je suis influenceur sur
les réseaux sociaux hier je suis passé
dans cette émission catastrophique on a
dit des choses alors qu'on a su bien
dire on m'a fait passer pour un
influenceur de Dubaï hyper qui s'est
fait refaire quatre fois il y a quoi
dedans dans l'opération et on l'a pas
dit la circoncision
bien sûr quand j'avais 8 ans parce qu'on
m'a demandé combien j'en ai fait et les
amygdales
4 fois on vient me [__] dans une
émission scandale avec des gens qui
payent 5 € l'injection qui vont se faire
dans des trucs complètement pourri le
chirurgien qui va l'opérer lui rappelle
les risques encourus lors de
l'intervention
bien que c'est un silence soit très très
rare une kératop pigmentation autrement
dit une sorte de tatouage de la cornée
la couleur a été fabriquée sur mesure
pour correspondre au verre souhaité par
sherine le chirurgien l’injecte dans la
cornée de la jeune femme il y a des gens
qui vont jouer avec leurs yeux quand
même pour changer de couleur de dans les
yeux pour ils peuvent être aveugles moi
c'est
de la débilité responsabilité c'est
qu'ils ont de l'argent à [__] en l'air
ils veulent balancer de l'argent
merci Benjamin d'être là merci Benjamin
près d'un an après le début de tes
nombreuses provocations quand tu revois
cette vidéo tu te dis quoi
ça te fait rire
[Musique]
cette vidéo qu'est-ce que je me dis la
question c'est la question
bordel
j'ai l'impression que les bandes sont
énervées ce soir tu fais plus de vidéos
comme ça ça y est non j'en ai pas fait
depuis quelques temps
tu fais quoi maintenant je viens de
finir d'écrire un livre pourquoi sur ton
histoire ouais c'est ce que j'ai vécu
ouais tu dis quoi dans ton livre
je parle des personnes qui sont
harcelées je parle des personnes qui
sont sur les réseaux exposés rapidement
je parle de ce que c'est que d'être
harcelé sur les réseaux et de façon
incontrôlée comme ça les gens est-ce
qu'ils ont conscience qu'ils ont pu
faire souffrir et ce qu'ils ont
conscience de souffrir parce que tu as
la bonne place qu'on va mettre la bonne
place qui sait qui a vraiment réellement
frappé des gens qui sait qui a
réellement harcelé qui c'est qui a
réellement été en vague qui c'est qui a
réellement été tout en groupe pour
attaquer une seule personne est-ce que
tu la referais c'était ça la question si
c'était à refaire un an avant je pense
que oui voilà
malgré tout ce qui vous est arrivé je
pense que oui pourquoi
ça a révélé des comportements chez les
gens que je pense bon il faut se
rappeler est-ce que tu seras plus jamais
la même personne que ce que tu as été
avant
vous jouez un rôle en fait on n'arrive
pas à vous cerner où est-ce que vous
êtes sous substance il y a peut-être
comme ça dans la vie tout le temps
il y a eu des rumeurs comme quoi tu
avais pensé à un moment à mettre fin à
tes jours est-ce que c'est vrai ouais
ouais tu t'es fait suivre ou pas depuis
finalement non
j'ai voulu aller en clinique pour me
faire interner
en fait je pensais que j'étais fou je
pensais que ça c'est important
et finalement personne n'a voulu
m'interner donc
je suis resté chez moi j'ai réfléchi sur
moi-même et maintenant j'ai un psy aussi
qui mais
ouais quand j'ai voulu vraiment être
aidé et être interné tout simplement je
n'ai pas été triste ou pas où tu es
heureux dans la vie
j'ai un peu beaucoup triste quand même
mais c'est oui c'est ma personnalité un
peu mélancolie quoi
avant tout ce qui était tombé dessus ou
tu étais tu étais pareil avant la vidéo
peut-être un peu moins triste j'étais un
peu moins triste mais c'est parce que
oui c'est compliqué
[Musique]
dans famille nombreuse sur TF1 ils ont
arrêté famille nombreuses et ils se sont
reconvertis dans le zizi dans le cul cul
non mais c'est dans des vidéos qu'est-ce
que vous en dites enfants on peut
rappeler de calage alors de 17 à 3 ans
le 17 à 3 ans au petit on se doute bien
que on ne leur en a pas fait part
de 17 ans enfin le seul qui a accès
finalement à Internet
alors c'est vrai que moi j'ai pensé
depuis un petit moment j'en avais fait
part à Alex en fait j'ai une copine donc
donc je ne citerai pas le nom qui est
dans la téléréalité depuis très
longtemps qui est toujours à la télé à
l'heure actuelle et qui a une plateforme
sur Nîmes qui m'avait donc déjà parlé de
ça et donc moi j'avais parlé à Alexandre
de le faire et lui il était pas trop
chaud au début il me disait ouais non je
sais pas mais on est encore en tournage
avec TF1 à l'époque donc c'est un peu
paradoxal sachant que TF1 n'avait même
pas voulu nous suivre au village
libertin du Cap d'Agde alors qu'on leur
avait suggéré parce que c'était le gros
hein
il y a quelques temps je me suis dit
mais moi j'avais envie en fait de me
lancer là-dedans parce qu'en fait il y a
une demande c'est ce que je disais
vraiment une demande
voir en train de faire l'amour pas que
des photos enfin il y a vraiment de tout
on a accès à toutes les photos du mur
après et les vidéos
en privé et là par contre on a juste le
prix en fonction de la demande fonction
de ce qu'on nous demande de faire ah
d'accord parce qu'il vous demande genre
ça va de quoi de 50 à 150 euros
60 à 150 € par vidéo oui Léo notre fils
aîné qui a accès à Internet aux réseaux
sociaux etc on lui a posé la question
avant de se lancer là-dedans et s'il
avait mis un véto là dessus on n'aurait
pas fait est-ce que vous avez des
limites parce que vous dites que vous
êtes un couple exclusif vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure vous parlez de l'offre et
de la demande si demain il y a une offre
parce que là c'est des snaps
et j'ai refusé c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
trois jours effectivement il y a un
principe qui est l'offre et la demande
né on nous propose des choses qui ne
sont pas faisable pour nous notamment
l'échangisme et déjà tu en fréquente le
village du Cap d'Agde depuis des années
on n'a jamais pratiqué l'échangisme on
entend TF1 à apporter à atteinte à nos
enfants c'est pour ça qu'on a arrêté
l'émission exactement enfin n'était pas
raccord avec nos valeurs et ensuite ils
disent ça durera pas ce que vous faites
ça durera pas internet n'oublie rien ça
durera toujours là je vois 9 enfants 8
enfants 8 pardon
nous nos enfants en fait ils sont
heureux en fait voilà en fait c'est
l'essentiel et puis tant que on leur
donne de l'amour et puis surtout toi tu
étais pas inquiet pour tes enfants non
pas du tout non
tu as envie de leur dire quoi
je peux dire ce que tu veux ici apaisez
notre famille voilà nous en fait tant
qu'on est heureux c'est l'essentiel vous
pensez qu'à vous vous pensez pas vous
donner des enfants
mes enfants sont heureux dans 10 ans
il y a d'autres manières d'éduquer que
par la peur notamment la menace et parce
qu'on sait maintenant parler dernière
découverte en neurosciences que le
cerveau des enfants et à la fois
immature et fragile ce qui fait que
moins on utilise de méthode entre
guillemets qui soit contraignante et
stressante et mieux c'est on est obligé
de les punir à certains moments sinon
ils peuvent se mettre eux-mêmes en
danger et c'est grave et dans une
société comme on la voit avec toute
cette permissivité où on parle de retour
à l'uniforme de retour à la dictée on a
besoin d'autorité je trouve que c'est
pardon mais désastreux ce que vous êtes
en train de dire vous êtes une
tortionnaire éducative
[Applaudissements]
punir aujourd'hui ça veut dire quoi
c'est le bonnet d'âne c'est file dans ta
chambre vous vous rendez compte de ce
que vous dites vous êtes la France du
passé vous avez parlé d'uniformes mais
ça ne m'étonne pas de vous vous êtes la
France qui ne sait pas éduquer et vous
projetez sur vos enfants
je suis très heureux des enfants
j'aimerais parler en circonstance de
cause puisque j'étais une enfant de la
DASS et j'étais une enfant battue et à
force d'être réprimandé d'être puni de
se prendre des claques dans la gueule
des injustices des humiliations totales
alors effectivement ça fait de vous une
personne qui est complètement différente
avec des émotions des ambitions qui sont
complètement surdimensionnés mais ça ne
laisse des énormes séquelles mental et
affective donc je demande à tous les
gens qui ne regardent en aucun cas de
lever et de punir les enfants à des
des séquences et des émotions extrêmes
qui nous laissent des traumatismes à vie
dans l'affective et dans la vie
professionnelle ne portez pas la main
sur les enfants et ni sur les chiens je
parle des chiens également parce que
j'aime également les chiens moi j'ai pas
d'enfants mais effectivement j'ai éduqué
mon chien et ça c'est très bien passé
donc je
on peut s'arrêter là je pense que c'est
possible
effectivement fonctionne chez les
animaux et j'ai sans doute chez les chez
les petits chez les enfants aussi mais
moi ce que je voulais dire c'est que
l'amour est chez les enfants ne suffit
pas il faut mettre un cadre parce que
sinon quand on voit les parents qui
disent ah non mais on le laisse faire
c'est éducation positive et ils font
n'importe quoi il faut quand même
apprendre la frustration des enfants par
exemple mes parents ne m'ont jamais puni
donc j'ai jamais été frustré et du coup
à l'âge adulte aujourd'hui j'ai beaucoup
de mal à gérer mes frustrations je
supporte pas que d'être frustré ou qu'on
me dise non par exemple et c'est pour ça
que quand on est petit on n'a pas envie
d'avoir une punition mais je pense que à
l'âge adulte après au final on se dit
c'est quand même mieux pour la
répercussion sur les enfants si je peux
rebondir sur la frustration je pense que
ce qui est important c'est d'apprendre
aux enfants à la gérer la frustration
[Musique]
c'est vous qui avez pris cette décision
d'afficher d'afficher les images de vos
voleurs ça s'est passé mardi vous le
voyez sur les images par 10 derniers et
puis et puis je dis je suis allé porter
plainte j'ai hésité parce que fait la
queue deux heures et puis après à la
police on vous dit on va faire ce qu'on
peut mais
n'espérez rien il y a tellement de gens
qui attendaient après moi que je me suis
sentais que et puis samedi je me suis
dit
je vois pas pourquoi on pourrait faire
ça en France aujourd'hui donc je me suis
dit il faut y aller
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire est-ce qu'on
doit laisser faire ou pas d'afficher
leur visage est-ce que vous allez dire
un moment c'est plus peur j'ai plus peur
parce que parce que c'est trop fréquent
il faut savoir que ce que vous voyez
chez moi c'est c'est encore une fois
dans tous les commerces de France et
c'est à peu près 2 à 5% du chiffre
d'affaires de ces commerçants rien ne
justifie la vendetta rien ne justifie
d'exposer d'afficher les gens comme ça
ce sont les réseaux sociaux
il fait quoi alors c'est quoi ta j'ai
envie de savoir c'est quoi ta solution
la solution c'est la police
j'ai l'impression que de victimes je
suis passé à coupable c'est ça ah oui
monsieur oui
franchement c'est très grave moi je me
dis tant pis je vais prendre pour les
autres allez-y prenez un nom de prison
de justice je prendrai un avocat
parce que malheureusement quand tu
rentres dans un dans un commissariat de
police il y a ça dans le dossier et de
toute manière il serait arrêté il y
aurait déjà trois ans à peu près trois
ans à peu près d'instruction avant que
eux déjà soit en prison ou de toute
manière il ne risque rien moi quand je
sors d'un supermarché aux États-Unis
sans carte d'identité on m'affiche sur
tous les réseaux et vous vous avez
affiché des voleurs je suis d'accord
avec vous parce que justement si tout le
monde faisait ça les commerçants qui
payent 3000 euros et qui font pas
énormément d'argent de loyer peuvent
justement se défendre ce débat il est
fou en fait on est en train de se
demander si quelqu'un qui a subi un vol
donc une victime est allée trop loin
donc s'il est coupable mais à mon avis
c'est qui les coupables c'est ceux qui
respectent rien qui vole et qui mettent
des entreprises dans la merde ou c'est
ceux qui veulent simplement que la loi
soit appliquée donc moi je comprends ce
qu'elle fait monsieur bravo encore une
fois faut se demander poser la question
pourquoi vous l'avez fait parce que
quand on m'a porté plainte il ne se
passe rien et moi pardon je ne vois même
pas le problème d'afficher la tête d'un
voleur pourquoi c'est il va trop long
afficher la tête d'un voleur qui dit que
c'est le voleur la présomption
[Applaudissements]
sur Twitter mais en fait tu te rends
compte de ce que tu dis mais je ne suis
pas dit qu'il a volé il est là tu t'es
fait faire une opération des yeux
t'inquiète arrête du cul ou quoi il est
là dessus
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'il faisait du rangement de
votre magasin déconner il y a un moment
si vous devriez aller les récupérer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]